un petit déjeuner gratuit à l'école
c'est du réchauffé retour en 1954
première fois qu'il est proposé aux
écoliers avec un simple verre de lait à
l'époque c'est une idée du président du
conseil pierre mendès-france un verre de
lait donc du sucre du calcium et des
protéines
l'idéal pour pallier les carences
d'après guerre mais pas seulement
le gouvernement français espère en
résorbant l'excédent de la production
laitière répondre le goût du lait dans
le pays mais il y a une autre raison
plus surprenante vu d'aujourd'hui ses
larmes pacifique
engagé dans la lutte contre l'alcoolisme
car dans les années 50 le vin et la
bière pouvait sans problème se trouvait
sur la table du petit déjeuner deux
décennies plus tard en 1976 nouvelle
opération les aux écoles lancée par la
commission européenne cette fois et ça
fait plaisir en annonçant ce matin est
fier de le prendre par la mission crois
que c'est très bien façon dont les
enfants
et leurs enfants depuis les années 80
certaines écoles qu'ils ont décidé
propose un petit déjeuner ou plus
exactement une collation à 10 heures
avec des aliments variés une pomme l'est
et surtout des petits gâteaux
une collation c'est bien beau mais
attention dans les années 2000 des
nutritionnistes alerte sur de potentiels
risques d'obésité
quand on regarde les tickets dont on lit
26% de beurre on ne mettrait pas sur une
tartine de pain un quart de l'épaisseur
de la tranche de pain sous forme de
beurre donc ces trous le petit déjeuner
fait aujourd'hui son retour dans une
version équilibrée dans les
établissements en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire rep et rêvent plus
expérimentés dans huit académies
[Musique]